Beschleunigt fliegen. Beim beschleunigten Flug ist es wichtig, dass ihr probiert, die Hände ganz oben streck zu halten.
Ihr dürft auch, wenn ihr wollt, euch so ein bisschen an den hinteren Tragegurten halten, weil wir können im beschleunigten Flug nur noch mit Gewichtsverlagerung steuern.
Und wenn das eben nicht ausreicht, dann nehmen wir noch einen ganz leichten Zug am hintersten Tragegurt mit.
Also das heißt, Beschleuniger richten, oder wie beschleunigt man, wenn er da, so wie ich, gut in die erste Schlaufe reinkommt,
geht er mit der Ferse in diese erste Schlaufe, tretet die ein bisschen so weit, dass er mit dem zweiten Fuß auf die nächste Stufe zurücksteigen könnte
und dann den zweiten Fuß ebenfalls auf diese Stufe zurück holen.
Ihr seht, ich habe da so einen flexiblen, das haben die meisten von euch, wenn ihr Stange habt, geht das ein bisschen einfacher.
Ja, dann suchen wir so ein bisschen die Symmetrie mit den Füßen und dann drücken wir den Beschleuniger ganz langsam voll hoch.
Und im Idealfall ist dann der Beschleuniger, so wie hier rechts, Rolle über Rolle drüber oder zumindest Rolle auf Rolle drauf.
Hier links seht ihr, haben wir noch ein bisschen Distanz zwischen den einzelnen Rollen.
Ist jetzt nicht viel, das kommt halt dadurch, dass wir da eine gewisse Asymmetrie drinnen haben.
Wenn ich die Beine weiter rausnehme, dann seht ihr, haben wir da,
Symmetrie und die Rollen wirken garantiert.
Das wäre voll beschleunigt und jetzt ist wichtig, steuern nur noch mit Gewichtsverlagerung.
Ja, wenn das nicht ausreicht, dann dürfen wir ganz leicht am hinteren Tragerohr ziehen.
Also ein Zentimeter, höchstens zwei, also da haben wir wenig Arbeitsbereich.
Gut, Beschleuniger ausleiten, einfach neutral hinsetzen oder wenn wir eine Kurve machen auf die andere Seite,
machen wir die zuerst fertig und dann neutral hinsetzen.
Und langsam zurück aus dem Beschleuniger gehen.
Die letzten paar Zentimeter könnt ihr dann von mir aus ausspicken lassen.
Wichtig ist, während dem beschleunigten Flug dürft ihr nicht mit der Bremse steuern.
Die Erklärung kommt nachher bei der Bremsstiftung.